we got randy from harrisonburg big randy
what's up brendan what's up theo coming
at you from harrisonburg virginia and i
got a debate club for you guys today
last time you guys were debating on
cinema and i want to know what you guys
think about if you're going to watch a
western
are you going to watch john wayne
western or you're going to watch clint
eastwood western
gang gang buzz buzz and for derrick and
cat
culture culture culture culture and
culture culture
uh here's the thing the real question is
who's more racist
john wayne and chris what are your deal
man
right now dude i'm just saying we go
back in time
also here's the thing were they racist
or was that just the way it was back
then for john wayne that was just the
time bro you you didn't want to bring up
john wayne tweets and [ __ ]
do they really yeah oh yeah i'm trying
to drag him under the bus no pun
intended
yeah i'm just saying john wayne had
twitter well no
but the yeah they tried to drag him
under the bus for saying like [ __ ]
against black people
in 1930 what's the culture corner i
think though he was in 1930
that's what i'm saying yeah yeah well i
mean yeah it just never ends
at a certain point people are [ __ ]
hard if you dragging people up through
the past for
and he's dead also clint eastwood's 90
still in movies direct and doing the
damn thing
and clint eastwood you want to talk
about bus lamps his entire world was a
bus lamp
he [ __ ] plane stewardess he [ __ ]
restaurant owners not he has so many
kids
yeah hell yeah dude that's clint
eastwood
to me it's clint eastwood all day i
didn't grow up with john wayne
well that's so i understand was the 30s
he's definitely racist
but first of all dude if you were live
in the 30s you would probably be racist
too dude
all right yeah you got no argument
so just we've got to be understanding
where people were
i'm understanding i'm saying i like
clint eastwood more he made million
dollar baby
he made the mule which i [ __ ] hated
but either way he directed and
uh starred in it and he's 97 years old
dude at a certain point let's quit
saying start in it as opposed to
wandering around the set
it's getting a little bit wild right and
they just i think this is an unfair
topic because
most of our listeners and even myself
barely know who john wayne is preach
you know john wayne i think it's a porn
guy you know
yeah i thought john wayne was in black i
thought john wayne was the guy who
banged uh pharah abrams
but i respect this guy and um
yeah doesn't miss either bro he makes
great movies
i'm too young for john wayne i'd have no
id i couldn't name one movie
all i know is he got brought up recently
in the news for being racist
and it was the 30s so he gets a pass but
it's also the news everybody's racist in
the news the news is a bunch of [ __ ]
tards
you know what i'm saying if the news
we're here right now i'd [ __ ] them up
bro yeah me too
this is what i give you cnn you [ __ ]
hard
gang bro 73 eastwood yeah yeah no one
knows
beast wood dude also your name is clint
bro it's like [ __ ] with an
n in it his son
uh is an actor too yeah oh wow you know
about his son dude
gay guy okay wow i can't talk about a
son being in hollywood he was in fast
and furious
oh i have no idea about clint eastwood's
son dude because i'm talking about i'm
thinking about chicks over here
you're such an idiot yeah such an idiot
but i'm an idiot that's
hanging out with tits bro
not you over there bro
hey what frat did you come from deal
[Laughter]
you got roofies in your pocket as well
let me relax bro
t-a-t tampa alpha tats bruh
okay i'm tapping tata's dude
not d-i-k over there dude what do you
got with the
thing about clint is with son bro i'm
not thinking about it it's just a
reference bro
i got ice on your head bro your [ __ ]
brain is
gay bro
[Music]
is